hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news
on today's programme britain on track
for periods of 100
renewable electricity in 2025
a warning that the arctic could be at an
irreversible
tipping point triggering the
disappearance of ice
by the arctic summer and the climate
change driven
frost that's chilling and killing wine
crops
in france
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now we've heard the warnings
but now scientists straight from an
expedition in the arctic
say ice is receding more quickly than
ever before
more than 200 researchers were involved
in the expedition in which a german
research ship
spent a year collecting data on the
impact of climate change in the region
the expedition leader professor marcus
rex said he believes the western arctic
ice shield
will disappear if nothing is done well
joining me now is climate scientist dr
ella gilbert uh dr gilbert good to talk
to you
that's a depressing verdict it
absolutely is
and the fact is that polar science and
the polar regions
are the canary in the coal mine when it
comes to climate change
the loss of arctic the ice is happening
before our very eyes
and it sounds like it's continuing to do
so if we
hearing it straight from the horse's
mouth and do you believe that we've
already gone past an irreversible
tipping point
without seeing the data for myself i
wouldn't like to comment on that um
but the situation is really clear arctic
sea ice
has been plummeting in recent decades
and it continues to do so
the less uh mitigation action that we
take the worse it'll be
so the time to act is yesterday and
the worst that the more we delay and the
less
mitigation actions we take the the worse
the future outcomes will be
and what happens if we don't have an
arctic ice shield
well the the arctic sea ice that
professor rex was referring to
um it's very bright and white and
reflective so
the ice caps in general and polar ice in
the polar regions reflects lots of
incoming sunlight so when we start to
lose
that sea ice um it exposes the dark
ocean water beneath it and that absorbs
much more
energy and radiation uh which starts to
melt the sea ice even faster so it's
this
mutu this reinforcing positive feedback
where
warming causes loss of sea ice which
causes more warming which causes more
loss of sea ice
and this has quite far-reaching impacts
beyond just the arctic
it influences the weather in the
northern hemisphere for example and it
influences things like
the ocean circulation so it's not just a
case of what happens in the arctic stays
in the arctic it's
an effect and a phenomenon with really
global consequences
yeah the ripples go far and wide don't
they dr ella gilbert good to talk to you
thank you
well in the next four years all
electricity in britain could be 100
powered by renewables for a period of
time that's according
to the national grid electricity system
operator report
well let's take a look now at our data
dashboard it shows us the real-time
power mix
in great britain at the moment you can
see that 32
of electricity is coming from fossil
fuels 49
of it from renewable sources and 19
from nuclear but the study shows that at
times that number there that fossil
fuels number could be zero
in britain in 2025 meaning renewables
could account for 100 of electricity
during a period of time let's find out
how
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
and helping to hit those targets and
indeed happening
this very week the world's longest
undersea
electric cable is being switched on this
week with testing already underway
the 720 kilometer interconnector
will be used to trade clean energy
between the uk and norway
as part of plans to cut emissions and
boost offshore wind
interconnectors supplied around 8 of uk
power in 2019 and that figure is
expected
to double within the next five years
well wind power is a big factor in the
push towards renewables and
net zero and as we approach cop26 and on
this global wind day
a new global wind coalition is being
launched to encourage countries all
around the world
to urgently scale up wind power in the
uk
wind energy now provides nearly a
quarter of the country's total power
generation
globally wind energy capacity is rising
fast
90 gigawatts of new wind capacity was
installed between 2019
and 2020 for a total of 743
gigawatts in 2020. much of that growth
was driven
by explosive growth in china followed by
the united states
but this initiative aims to boost wind
as a source of clean energy
in countries traditionally dependent on
fossil fuels
by the end of 2020 south africa for
example had just
2.5 gigawatts of onshore wind capacity
but by 2030 they want to increase that
figure to over
14 gigawatts well joining me now
is natan b futinatuli she's the ceo
of the south african wind association
really good to talk to you i can
describe the ambitions of south africa
there
how much energy currently comes from
wind in
south africa currently in south africa
we have
a 2.5 gigawatts installed capacity which
is currently being generated
and feeding into the grid and we've got
a pipeline of about 800 megawatts which
is projects that are concluding
a construction and and we have a very
big pipeline for the next 10 years
of 14 gigahertz for new projects to be
built
every year like other governments
globally south africa has committed to a
net zero
target and so how this campaign helps us
is by joining forces
with leading companies and associations
from around the world
to help governments to scale up their
ambition for
the ndcs and for and and for climate
action for crop26 so really as we move
towards taking more action and work
together to scale up wind power
and to reach the next row targets we are
encouraging governments to
step up and take more action and
scale up the ambition nato before we
talk a lot don't we about g7
countries and what they're doing in
their move towards renewables
it sounds like we very much should be
talking about countries like south
africa as well
yes countries like south africa are
really um joining
the big countries in terms of uh the the
shift in the way that we generate power
and we are shifting from the coal-fired
generation to clean energy we've got
very ambitious targets
as a country uh which also follows a
global trend because we see it globally
that there is a shift
from um a coal-fired power to
to to a sources like wind energy
and solar energy and therefore south
africa
is obviously benefiting from the global
action but there is a lot happening on
the ground
in the country we've seen a lot in terms
of shift
in the policy space we have seen a lot
of action happening and a government
really taking action
to to to to scale up their ambition and
to
approve policies that were actually
blocking the deployment of renewable
energy
natomi flutie naturally really good to
talk to you thank you
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now
and the government's being warned that
its free trade deal with australia could
have a devastating impact on the
environment
green campaigners have raised concerns
the agreement could lead to increased
carbon emissions
and undermine britain's animal welfare
standards they say the government should
not reward countries without dating
farming systems which are fueling
the climate crisis wildfires in the
rocky mountains
are burning more frequently now than in
the past
2000 years that's according to a new
study by the university of montana
and wyoming scientists there collected
data from high elevation forests in
colorado
and compared it with fire history
records they believe
wildfire activity has increased due to
hotter and drier conditions
caused by climate change and a london
company has been named as
one of the world economic forum's top
100
tech pioneers for their work to tackle
plastic pollution
polymateria has developed a
biodegradable plastic
which decomposes after a couple of
months and is still able to be recycled
during
its usable lifetime so even if it does
get thrown away as litter it will break
down
into harmless waxes rather than
microplastics
well let's take you back now to that
data dashboard one of our top stories
today that renewables like
wind could power 100 of britain for
periods of time in just
four years that's according to new
research by the national grid
electricity system operator
again this here shows you the real time
power mix where your electricity
is coming from in great britain and this
here is what the university of oxford
tells us is
human-induced warming since the mid-19th
century
ticking up as we speak we can also see
the urgency this estimate here suggests
we have only
until early 2033 before global
temperatures rise
by 1.5 degrees celsius the optimal limit
as agreed by many countries as part of
the 2015 paris agreement
and finally this is the total amount of
co2 emissions
2.41 trillion tons again
ticking up while we're watching it
and finally wine production in france
has been under threat from rare freezing
temperatures this year
an international group of scientists
have been examining the role
of climate change it seems a bit
counterintuitive
that climate change is a problem with
these frosts
and when we just look at the frost in
april we indeed find
that they would have been even colder
without climate change so climate change
does lead to
fewer frosts in april
[Music]
climate change also leads to
higher temperatures early in the year so
in march
in particular
this year in april when these frost hit
the leaves
had already come out so the buds had
burst and so there were a lot of young
leaves that could be damaged
in a world without climate change these
leaves
would have still be dormant and the
damages
would not have happened this problem is
not going to go away
[Music]
well that's all from us for today
tomorrow is the uk
ready for the impacts of climate change
we look at the findings of a new report
that'll be at the same time tomorrow
here on
sky news hope to see you then